[Music]
tips the season for Kelly Clarkson and
it's a first for new son Remi what I
know it's so second child syndrome y'all
but like I okay cuz I learned from River
last Christmas [ __ ] I was going on he's
seven months old
so he's gonna be like like you know
Kelly telling us she loves the holidays
in fact she and husband Brandon
Blackstock have had their Nashville home
decorated for some time now
and I'll be honest with you actually the
lights out Center oh we're on before
Halloween and that's because we threw a
masquerade ball and I thought well
that's perfect you know it like king
over the evening and we're like those
rednecks and it's lights on it weird
times of the year Kelly is also
celebrating this year by putting on a
holiday benefit concert for local
Nashville charities and this year's
December the 16th concert will include a
listers like Kelsea Ballerini and
stepmother-in-law reba mcentire giving
back she feels is part of being a good
mom I've never been more confident as a
woman as I am as a mother there's always
so much going on and and I think that
that gives you so much confidence the
fact that like yeah I feel like I'm I
feel like I don't know my kids might end
up in very very something but I feel
like I'm nailing it and I nail it most
days but let's be real there are days
that I'm gonna have a bottle and a Bible
oh geez I gonna make it
[Music]